y si estás a argelia angola y ahora a la
republica del congo italia ha firmado
recientemente múltiples acuerdos de
suministro de energía con varios países
africanos forma parte de un movimiento
europeo para reducir su dependencia de
la energía rusa tras la invasión de
ucrania el último acuerdo se firmó en
brazzaville
un objetivo bonita es una prioridad para
italia que requiere un esfuerzo
colectivo de todo nuestro gobierno para
reducir nuestra dependencia energética
de un solo país
[Música]
el ministro de asuntos exteriores
italiano afirmó que el objetivo es
aumentar el suministro de gas natural
licuado procedente de la república del
congo en más de 4500 millones de metros
cúbicos en otro acuerdo con argelia se
pactó el envío de nueve mil millones de
metros cúbicos adicionales de gas a la
península para el próximo año junto con
1.500 millones de metros cúbicos al año
de angola italia recibe actualmente el
40% del gas natural de rusia cada año
este es el primer paso de muchos porque
tenemos una cooperación diversificada
con italia creo que todo está preparado
para una fuerte cooperación y sobre todo
una asociación estratégicas
el primer ministro italiano dice que la
diversificación del gas ruso es posible
pero podría llevar tiempo
esto no es algo que se puede hacer en un
mes así que quizá en los próximos dos o
tres años podamos reducir
significativamente las importaciones de
rusia pero hasta ahora ni no podemos
sustituir sobre todo el petróleo las
importaciones de rusia e imposturas ya
la empresa energética italiana eni
afirma que a partir del otoño llegarán
al país mayores flujos de gas natural de
fuentes distintas a rusia